How do you describe software engineering to dates without them getting it'd be
really important. Help me.
What's popping. Good morning.
I hope you guys are having an offense tastic Thursday,
that today I'm just going to get a few engineers to answer some of these
questions that you asked me on the previous blog. If you haven't seen that,
it's this one, a lot of good questions and hopefully good answers from us.
One more thing. I just want to say, thank you so much for 2,500 subscribers. Um,
wow. Like, yeah, we grew pretty fast, so I'm pretty happy about that. It's all.
Thanks to you guys. So thank you so much.
I'll also talk about the AirPod giveaway at the end of this video.
So stick around. All right. So it's time to go to work.
You slacked me. I know you are. I want to make a video of me.
Can you answer some CS questions for me? And once he asks questions,
she has advice. Questions. You have some rain. Come, come, come, come, come.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's pop. And dude, what's up, dude?
I I'll make a video of me. No, really? Come on. Just ask some questions.
I need engineers to ask. Okay. Dope. Dope. Dope. Let's go.
All right. All right. All right. Ready?
What let's you guys get close to clinicals, but like you're my friends,
you know, pretend you're my friend. What's up guys. All right.
So remember I did a Q and a before,
or I asked you to do a Q and a on my last video when I had a thousand
subscribers. Now I'm going to answer that. So let's go through it. Okay.
First question by Omar.
Santiago is software engineer and easy major.
It is for me. What do you mean? Why does it make any sense? Okay.
So in Waterloo,
there is a software engineering major and it is it's,
it's not as easy as the computer science major, which is what I did.
Next question. Hmm. Wait, there's a difference. Yeah,
there was a difference CS major.
So we have engineering and also we have like sciences.
So I took a bachelor of science in computer science,
and then most people can get an engineering degree in sovereign engineer,
hurricane. How'd you get how'd you learn to get so good at break. Dancing
is not good. That's not true. My video. I was pretty godly.
Oh my God. But yeah, I was just born like,
Oh. This question. So long. Next
question. There's so many questions. Okay. Jake,
Nicole asks I find tech quite intimidating,
so channel's definitely an eye-opener. Thanks.
So what do tech companies care about which university you went to or is it
really down to internships and experience when starting in the industry? Um,
I don't think that your school matters too much,
but it does matter in terms of like what companies might come to like career
fairs, just how good your career is.
Like you probably like at your school is smaller.
You might have to put in more effort to reach out two.
I get the impression that tech people are quite busy and I do see some people
coding on public transportation. So how's life outside of tech job. Well,
my life is great, but,
but that's because I'm a data scientist and we don't do coding as much,
but yeah, I don't know life outside of tech, but for me,
I just do a lot of videos lately. So I don't really have a social life.
You guys have a social life? Yeah. I think work life balance is pretty good.
It's just that there are ups and downs, I guess.
So sometimes it gets like really busy and sometimes a lot of downtime.
So I don't think we're always busy.
How long does it take to learn a language before being qualified to use it for
work? I don't think you even need to learn the language before you're qualified
because just don't tell them that you don't know it. You'll be fine.
You can tell them it's fine. No, like if you want a job,
just tell them, you know, that language. And then once you get the interview,
that's when you learn the language, am I right? That's a terrible advice.
Just call them which languages, you know?
And they'll let you code in that language. And once you get to the company,
you can learn whatever language they use. Yeah. That's what I meant. I mean,
yeah. You could learn the language on the job, but yeah.
Are you still doing the regular blogs if you mean my startup series? Yes.
Episode three is coming out soon. I'm probably going to publish it February 1st.
So you have to be on the lookout for that favorite music. K-pop all right.
Another long question. All right. Number one.
How do you rate your university experience at Waterloo? It was great.
No, all you're really selling your soul right here. It was fine.
Lots of internships. Really good at a lot of friends. Um, yeah.
Courses are pretty easy. How did you start learning to code?
I went to college and there was a code. Why didn't you take the CS class?
Oh, well cause, cause my brother took the CS class, so then they,
he told me that there's lots of money in tech. So then I, I started doing tech.
Oh, what inspired you to become a programmer? Yeah, it was lucrative.
So I wanted to know what are TV shows you like to watch?
What do you like to watch? Do you like
[inaudible], what's your favorite city in the entire world? Soul.
[inaudible] I'm a career. Boop. What advice would you give to a teenager?
Trying to make it out there in a tech world.
Make sure you do want to come to tech before you decide.
Cause you're still a teenager and uh, yeah, I would,
I would also suggest you to get a girlfriend before coming to college.
Cause it gets in tech, in tech, in computer science. Yes.
It's true. It's true.
Are there any downsides to working in tech
downsides? Yeah. I don't know. You just have too much money and I'm like,
this is hard to like true. Is that true?
Like everyone's in tag and then it's just like your normal. Yeah.
So lack of diversity. That's that's one problem. Like I'm trying to make,
you know, artistic friends, but you know, none of these people are artistic.
So how do you know why Jennifer
[inaudible] alright. Next cherry Berry asked what colors are under beds.
Okay. Real question. Do you actually intend to start a startup? Okay.
Roll answer. Uh, I'm on a TN visa, so I'm not allowed to,
to start my own business or have any other income, other debt.
My actual job right now. Sasquatch cat. Squatch ask Lamar.
I love your sense of humor. Personality. Thanks. All right. Your videos
[inaudible] was a question.
My question is what tips advice would you give to a high schooler?
Trying to become a Sweden? The future?
Any do's or don'ts love your videos by the way.
I hated since in high school. Oh,
what'd you what'd you end up coming back then because I took it again in college
and it was a lot better. Um,
I would suggest doing a lot of side projects,
like just making a website for yourself,
even thought would be good and internships. Now high schoolers have internships.
Now don't do an internship before you go to college. Just take that summer up.
Oh yeah. True. Go get a girlfriend.
Look at me now. All right. Your videos,
your videos provide so much detailed information about internships.
I absolutely love it. Question.
How do you compare the work and tech companies and quantify Nance.
And can you intro your brother?
Why does my brother always get the spotlight in Quantico?
I guess the biggest difference is that quantum researchers are versus
FinTech companies. Software engineers are first citizens, Jesse Chan.
What is one thing about tech industry programming that annoys you?
What is something you wish you could change about the industry?
Love your videos. Keep it up. Thank you. I guess,
for females going into tech, it's pretty different.
There's a lot of pain points, obviously because of the gender,
gender. I want to say inequality, like lack of diversity gender.
Um, for example, during one of my internships,
I was the only girl in the team of 10 engineers.
And that's pretty to deal with, especially culturally,
um, like they like things that you might may not necessarily like,
and it's hard to fit in,
but those are just one of those things that are improving slowly.
And that's why we need more girls to come into tech so that that trend can
change. Congrats are a milestone bro.
Question for you as someone who seems quite busy on a daily basis,
what would you say are some of your keys to productivity and accomplishment on a
way keys to productivity and accomplishing your goals? I guess,
manage your time. I mean, so
I guess once I found the most useful is, I don't know,
just start using a calendar and time box your stuff, you know,
to make sure that you don't go overboard. Kevin Walter asked,
can you get a job at a big company that USA as a terminal graduate students?
Yes. Oh yeah. Probably.
You just have to apply to like a big company or any company that would sponsor
you and they'll give you like an H1B visa and you could stay
exhorted his when applying for your first tech job.
How do you know when you're ready? At what point do you just go for it?
And what advice do you have to be ready for it? First tech job.
You're always ready. You're always ready. Okay. Just believe in yourself.
Just apply. Just apply. Because like, if you fail then,
okay. You know, you're not ready, but like
[inaudible] what is it like working with other professionals,
software engineers, professional software engineers like us.
Oh really? Oh, we're very professional.
Very demanding. You know, they're very professional, but yeah, no,
it's just the same thing as working with normal engineers, I guess.
I don't know. It's the same as working in a school project. Kind of.
Do you have any pieces of advice such as things to avoid in the workplace?
As in asking dumb questions? Wow. Come on, man.
There's no such thing as a dumb question. Kind of.
Well, like you should always, you shouldn't just ask everything.
You should still like try to figure it out on your own.
And if after like 30 minutes or an hour and you still don't get it,
then you should ask them. Who is your current favorite music? Artists.
Black. Oh, what would you say?
What is your skincare routine before moving on from one language to another.
How comfortable should I be in the first week?
And you're just looking at my skin. It's not that good. Why, why?
Why is he asking you? [inaudible]
uh what's because I'll ask him the girls. Okay, fine.
What is your senior routine? Korean skincare team. Okay.
Well, I can tell you mine versus you use toner,
then you use moist or like face wash.
Now you use tone and then you baseline what? My work is around.
Wait, wait. Okay. Funny face. Okay. Face wash and tone. Okay.
Clearly I don't do it.
I actually just put water in my face and then I put moisturizer. Yeah.
I'd open wash my face to be honest, but yeah. Um,
what else is called the mask and like put the mask on sometimes masks mask.
Okay. What's your favorite part about your current job?
I think my favorite part is to pupil.
Aw, wait, can you do it again? But with like more genuine,
my favorite part is the people. Oh,
sorry. [inaudible]
another great video Jolla. Yeah.
I can see you definitely hitting those 10 K before the summer. Anyways.
One question. Are you actually working right now? If so,
what tech do you work on your daily life?
So I'm actually a data scientist and I worked for a decently large company in
Silicon Valley, Simon FOM asks,
what are some important attributes you like to see in a fellow software
engineer? Well, I mean, it's not like I'm a manager or anything,
so it doesn't really matter. But I mean,
I usually like engineers who also have empathy,
meaning they actually know what they're building and who they're building it for
so that, you know, they care more about the product.
When you build stuff also wonder code doesn't suck. Right?
Cause there's a lot of code out there. I've seen your dis
good mentors being good mentors. Like if you know how to do something,
just teach the other person and don't be a Dick about it.
Pineapple asks K as a lot of my heart is set on iOS developer.
Well, to answer this question, um, to be an iOS developer the best way, wait,
I don't, I don't know what that means. I think it's just one major.
Do you need a major? I was like, what is the better? Yeah, better it does.
I thought, well,
maybe it is made better to be too good to be an iOS
developer. Is it better? Is it better to be an iOS developer?
I better answer this one.
First C S med heart that said I always
developer [inaudible] tengo, mucho, dinero,
whatever. Screw it.
[inaudible] how do you describe software engineering?
Two dates followed them getting it'd be really important. Help me.
That's a good question. Um,
I never tell them at first that I'm a software engineer or I work in tech.
So say that you get to build cool, cool products.
Lots of cool products that you use daily. Yeah. Oh,
that's true. Yeah. If you're in a big tech company or like a popular one,
like Snapchat, you can just say, Oh, I work for Snapchat.
And then they're just like, Oh really? Those are the girls.
I mean, it's not an exciting company.
You're, dude. Just keep it short. Yeah. I guess, I don't know.
Describe your hobbies and stuff like yeah. Right.
David Kwan asked great videos looking to get in the tech industry myself on my
first co-op term for systems and design engineering at Wharton right now.
Oh wow. Nice. A fellow Walter, the kid. So these videos help a lot.
This is pretty general,
but people always say to do projects and I was wondering what sorts of things to
do that we'll get good experience and or good.
I actually don't like, um, like it's fair,
but I don't like people who only do projects because it looks good on your
resume. Cause I don't know, because first of all,
it doesn't even seem like you care about it. But I mean,
if you really have to then yeah.
I'd probably do some web projects full stacks just to show that, you know,
every part of the stack, but yeah. I mean,
I would recommend you do something that you enjoy and you have fun because it
would probably make it better anyways, if you do like doing it. All right. Okay.
So thank you so much for all of these questions. Um,
I hope this was helpful for you guys. Uh, yeah,
I guess I'll see you later back at home. Peace.
Yeah. It's too cheesy. I guess I'll do it. Yeah. I can't reach,
I can't reach. All right.
So I just want to say big,
thanks to all my friends who participated in the video.
If you want to follow them on Instagram, you can. I'll just put them down below.
Also. I want to say AirPods, the contest is still running.
It's going to run until January 30th and here it is.
These are the AirPods that you will receive. Ooh,
man, it's disgusting. The contest is not over,
so it's not too late to participate.
All you have to do is you follow me on Instagram and on Twitter.
So that will give you two entries to the contest.
So for the questions I did not answer so, so sorry,
I just didn't have enough time and it would make the video too long. But uh,
if you messaged me on Instagram,
I will answer you and I'll probably give a better answer and a serious answer.
So it's probably even better if you asked me on Instagram, once again,
thank you so much for watching you guys are the best. Thank you for the support.
I just want to say that, you know, because of you guys,
it really pushes me to make the first entertainment channel for tech people
by tech people. I just want to say again, this is really important to me,
but I just want to make tech more open and accessible and entertaining.
So if you liked what you saw,
don't forget to subscribe and also pressing the notification button so that you
can get notified.
Whenever I go live or a new video comes out and it was thanks so much.